odile maurin merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france
peut-être votre réaction sur ce rapport
d'amnesty international qui condamne une
nouvelle fois des détentions arbitraires
et des violences lors d'une
manifestation le 12 décembre dernier
vous l'avez vécu ça vous étonne il ya
quelques années on m'aurait dit
effectivement qu'on qu'on pouvait subir
des violences et encourir les foudres de
la justice
en manifestant je ne l'aurais pas cru
mais je les ai vécu effectivement depuis
fin 2010 8 je tiens à préciser
en ce qui me concerne que si je me suis
positionné devant un canon à eau pour le
bloquer au mois de mars 2010 19
c'est parce que je manifestais une
manière totalement pacifique ainsi que
les gens qui l'entouraient et que nous
avons été victimes de tirs de grenades
lacrymogènes et de canons à eau
sans sommation et que donc j'ai réagi en
en bloquant le camion à eau parce que je
venais subir des violences qui étaient
totalement inacceptables
le résultat c'est que j'ai subi d'autres
violences que j'ai eu 5 fracture du pied
et que alors que j'étais la victime je
me suis retrouvé en position d'accusé
accusé par des policiers de les avoir
violenté
il ya des vidéos s'il justement jusque
est mort voilà ces fameuses vidéos on
voit très clairement que vous ne
violente et pas les policiers que ça se
passe à véritablement comme ils l'ont
ils l'ont raconté comment la justice a
accueilli justement votre témoignage
votre vidéo le problème c'est que là
j'ai eu affaire à un magistrat qui a
simplement refusé de visionner les
vidéos qui montraient que j'avais été
violente et non pas le contraire et qui
montrait bien que la version des
policiers ne tenait pas la route
par exemple l'un d'entre eux prétendait
que j'avais blessé au genou outre le
fait qu'il portait les protections qui
qui empêchait de le blesser
mon quel pied ne pouvait pas le touché
au genou à moins qu'il a été
particulièrement petit atteint de
nanisme
il y avait des incohérences simplement
j'ai eu à faire un magistrat qui a
considéré que la parole des policiers
étaient d'évangile et que qui a refusé
tout simplement de visionner les vidéos
on voit mon innocence et la culpabilité
des policiers vous en ai toute la
procédure vous avez fait appel
alors oui j'ai fait immédiatement appel
simplement la fois que j'attende encore
une bonne année avant de pouvoir passer
en appel et j'ai subi pendant une année
une une interdiction de manifester qui
étaient totalement injustifiés et
injustifiables m'équipe a donc privé de
cette liberté fondamentale de cette
liberté constitutionnel de manifester et
je passe de nouveau en correctionnelle
ce doux c'est vrai et parce que le 7
novembre dernier alors qu'il me restait
quelques semaines d'interdiction de
manifester je venais d'apprendre
quelques jours avant que les services de
réanimation de l'hôpital de toulouse
était saturé et que donc allez commencer
le tri des malades et que les personnes
âgées les personnes handicapées allait
être sacrifiés elle est refusée d'accès
à la réanimation
comme cela s'est passé dans de
nombreuses régions de france raison pour
laquelle avec mon association
nous avons porté plainte et donc j'ai ma
vie et celle de mes pairs étant mise en
danger
j'ai estimé que je n'avais plus de
raisons respecter cette interdiction de
manifester
parce que c'était quelque chose d'assez
intolérable de être privés de ce droit
d'expression et parce que ma vie était
mise en danger
vous avez manifesté en suis pas caché
oui j'ai toujours eu peur de les
manifester mais j'ai toujours estimé que
je te fais dépasser cette peur parce que
le femmes la technique du gouvernement
et qui te continue c'est celle qui
considère consiste à terroriser le
mouvement social pour empêcher les gens
de manifester et je considère qu'on ne
doit pas céder à ce terrorisme d'état à
ce régime autoritaire qui effectivement
tentes ne nous priver de ce droit
d'expression constitutionnelle alors
l'institution policière ces derniers
mois a été décrié une grande
consultation voulue par l'état est en
cours un point pour réformer la folie ce
qu'elle a ressenti
vous avez aujourd'hui envers les
policiers écoutez d'abord je refuse de
mettre tout le monde dans le même panier
jeu il ya des policiers qui sont
républicaines
les policiers qui effectivement ne
n'abusent pas de leur force
et puis il ya les policiers qui sont en
roue libre et qui sont encouragés par
leur hiérarchie et cela effectivement je
les dénonce et je continuerai à les
dénoncer à les combattre
alors on voit encore ici et là des
gilets jaunes qui descendent dans la rue
on en voit aussi sur les ronds-points il
y en a tout de même nettement moins
qu'au début du mouvement est ce que vous
pensez que et bien c'est en train de
s'essouffler ou au contraire il va y
avoir second souffle alors je pense que
de toute façon les mobilisations avec le
temps ça évolue effectivement le système
qui consiste à terroriser les gens
fonctionnent plutôt bien puisque je
dirais neuf personnes sur dix se sentent
solidaires des gilet jaune mais pour
autant ne vont pas manifester parce que
moi je peux comprendre aussi
surtout quand vous êtes parents quand
vous êtes
faire voilà quand vous avez des
responsabilités familiales notamment
beaucoup de gens ont peur de se
retrouver en garde à vue voir en prison
parce que combien de fois les personnes
ont été accusées de violences alors que
quand vous voyez les images vous rendez
bien compte que la seule violence qui
s'est exercée c'est celle des forces de
l'ordre et ceci bien souvent sans motif
merci beaucoup odile maurin pour votre
témoignage ce matin dans la matinale
d'air france